how can we be sure
that saturday is the seventh day god
rested on in creation
in fact it's a three-point question
three-part question was the sabbath done
away with
how do we reconcile paul's book and the
sabbath keeping see colossians 2
16. all right so how do we know
that the seventh day was the day on
which god rested
god has never left himself without
witness to the truth
never let me give you the most obvious
defense of the seven-day sabbath there
is an
entire nation on the face of the earth
that has kept the center of the sabbath
for thousands of years
actually the law was given directly to
them that there might be custodians to
give it to other people
i'm referring to the jewish nation and
they
know that the sabbath is the seventh day
from sunset on friday
to sense that on saturday there's no
argument that can overthrow that now
let's use some common sense and some
honesty the christian world celebrates
easter
on the first day of the week sunday
because the whole christian world knows
christ rose on the first day so easter
is not celebrated on monday
or on saturday on wednesday it is
celebrated on
sunday the day on which christ rose the
christian world also regards this thing
called good friday
the day on which jesus died then the
simple question is what is the day that
lies between the two
and that day is saturday the seventh day
sabbath
it is you know this issue of the sabbath
is not a difficult one it just requires
simple honesty
and humility it is not a difficult task
to identify the day of rest people say
the calendar was changed the calendar
was not changed in the sense
that the order of the days were changed
that has remained
sunday to saturday from the memorial and
so the seventh day on which god rested
was the seventh day of the week the one
he requires of
us to observe and on which we should
avoid
work now the third part of the question
was was the sabbath done away with
no you see god's law is eternal his
sabbath has
not been done away with now attempts
have been made
with some success to institute
a different day of worship for reasons
not connected to righteousness let me
say that again
for reasons not connected to
righteousness
we have the popular day of worship in
christianity as
sunday this has no bible basis
whatsoever
but this change was predicted in daniel
7 25 speaking of the little horn
which is identified as the the roman
church
by not only adventists but for hundreds
of years the little horn
has been identified as the roman power
the roman church now
the bible says of that power and it
shall speak great words against the most
high
daniel 7 25 and shall wear out the sins
of the most high
and think to change times and laws
now think to change because this
so-called change
is not recognized by heaven so they
shall think to change times and laws
what do you understand
by times and lost well times
the sabbath for them has moved from
saturday to sunday that's a change in
time
think to change times and laws now the
second commandment does not exist
in the catholic catechism it is taken
out because it forbids the worship of
images and so we have think to change
times and laws but no human being can do
that because the bible says in daniel 2
he removes this king said of the kings
he changes the times and the seasons
it is god who can do that not a man uh
in james chapter 4 verse 12 there is one
lawgiver not two the bible says there's
one lawgiver who is able to save and to
destroy
that lawgiver is christ the father and
the father
now any attempt made by a human entity
is not recognized by heavens so yes
attempts were made and most of the
christian world observes a day enacted
by
human beings not by god as far back as a
321 a.d the count
the the the emperor constantine who
supposedly got converted to christianity
he issued an edict in 321 at the
march of 321 on the venerable day of the
sun
let magistrates and those living in the
cities rest
constantine passed that law but he
allowed those in the country to continue
to work the farms
because people have to eat in three 64 i
believe it is the council of laodicea
there were 50 cannons or laws that were
enacted at that council
which went between 363-6364
law number 29 says no one
shall do their eyes on sunday
or on sabbath on saturday instead they
should honor
the lord's day which they call sunday so
there was a law that forbid
that made illegal the observance of the
sabbath
not by god by the early church that had
drifted from the standards of right and
wrong
and so the change to sunday was not made
by god
it was made by man and we're told by in
acts 5 29 we ought to obey god
rather than man by the way the acid test
that's coming upon us
will be this same very test shall we
keep the seventh-day sabbath of god
on the first day of the week which shall
be enacted by
secular powers so attempts have been
made to change today
millions of people follow the results of
human devising
but god has never changed his day as a
matter of fact
when jesus was discussing the signs of
his second coming
and of the time of trouble which would
befall the jews in his day
a few decades after he died jesus warned
them in matthew 24 28
let not your flight be on the sabbath
day in the winter or on the sabbath
because he still expected them to keep
the sabbath
john the apostle john who lived the
longest of all the twelve
he died about a hundred six seven years
after jesus
died and went back to heaven that's when
the apostle john died
he wrote in first john chapter five
verse three
that keeping god's commandments is the
expression of
love it is one of the themes of his book
both his gospel
and his epistles revelation chapter 22
verse 14
the very last book of the bible blessed
are they that do his commandments
how can he do something that's done away
with and so the sabbath has not been
done away with
but human beings under the impetus of
satanic powers
and i cannot be pleasant about this
under the impetus
of satanic forces have passed human laws
that most people follow but god's
sabbath is still
the seventh day of the week and that has
not changed
amen thank you very much how do we
reconcile
paul's writings with the sabbath well
paul is a defender of the sabbath
paul is a defender of the law paul
writes
in romans 7 from verse 7 what shall we
say then
is the law sin god forbid now if the law
isn't sin there is righteousness because
the object of sin is righteousness
is the law sin god forbid nay i had not
known
sin but by the law for i had not known
lust
except the law had said thou shalt not
covet what is paul saying
the only way i knew what was wrong
was because there is a law in romans 3
31 paul writes do we then
make void the law through faith may we
establish the law
paul writes in first corinthians 7 19
circumcision is nothing and
uncircumcision is nothing
but the keeping of the commandments of
god now this is an astonishing statement
for a jew to say
circumcision is nothing because
circumcision was used just
that word was used to refer to the
entire jewish system
as a matter of fact many non-jews
non-jews were frequently called
the uncircumcised and jews were called
the circumcision
paul says circumcision is nothing
uncircumcision is nothing what counts is
keeping
the commandments of god then people
argue many christians argue well we are
new testament christians
we don't have to keep the law the law
was nailed on the cross
what did god do in the new covenant we
are new covenant christians
he writes the law in the heart of a
person that's what is done in the new
covenant
it does not destroy the law it removes
the law from stone
is placed in the heart that is what is
done under the new covenant
so those who say we're a new covenant
christians are not making sense a new
covenant christian his or her greatest
joy will be obey god
because under that covenant the law is
placed
in the heart of a person you read that
in jeremiah 31 33
hebrews 8 10 and hebrews 10 16.
all right i think